[Music]
after I brought you the similar legit
outline for the season 8 premiere in
this very area the outline for the
second episode of the final season that
is coming from the same source basically
in case you haven't seen my previous
video about a year ago I received this
outline for season 8 why I say it
seemingly legit is dutifully it's been
sent to me way before given Turin start
filming its final season and they told
the leaked photos and filming news that
followed seemed to be perfectly matching
with this outline as already stated I
have outlines for all the episodes of
the final season and I will share them
in the following days as you can tell by
title itself in this video bringing the
leaked outline of season 8 episode 2 if
you haven't seen my previous video in
which I broke down season premiere I
highly suggest you to do so because
almost everything in there seems to be
confirmed by the leaked photos and then
come back and watch this video before I
start let me warn you once again that
this leaked outline does seem to be
legit so if you don't want anything
spoiled it's time for you to close this
video now that you've been warned let's
take a look on this outline the outline
states that the episode starts at
Winterfell John and Danny finally arrive
there being created by the stark
children first
Johnny unites with all his siblings and
friends Sam tells John that they need to
speak in private on Midianites the
dragons fly above interval let me stop
here for a moment the season 8 premiere
so Johnny day and arrived at white
Harbor in the beginning of the episode
the unsullied and were seen approaching
Winterfell in its end with a Jackie as
well even though I expected John and
Danny to arrive straight at Winterfell
in the first couple of scenes of season
8 it seems like they will not until the
second episode one can only hope that
they didn't arrive too late to prepare
defenses sent equip all the soldiers to
the dragon los pepes
let me remind you that the seat of house
amber has already fallen in the amber
scene the season premiere sends up on
being told by brain that wall has fallen
did sent Ravens to the northern houses
whose seats are the farthest norm
settlements and even though she did
manage to say the Karstarks who fleet
car hole just before the army of the
Dead reached it she did not manage to
save yummers their castle de la skirt is
the furthest Noren castle in north and
by the time the rain brought the news it
was too late it seems that John might
finally reunite with his siblings and
friends and even though I'm excited to
see John area reunion I'm more eager to
see how the star children will react to
the near study area the outline also
continues with this episode sees many
other unions as well
Orion sensor reunited with the Hound re
also reunites with Genji Jorah and Sam
hagh Tyrion Sansa sure seen at some
point of the episode general sorry night
sweet ghost with all the main characters
being at Winterfell in totally makes
sense for some of them to finally
reunite and share couple of words it's a
very insensitive United Center Clegane
who's basically been their only true
friend south of interval the hunt helped
sense a lot back when both of them were
in King's Landing and even offered to
escort her back to safety which Center
unfortunately refused he also helped her
sister area trying to escort her back to
her family but unfortunately the red
wedding occurred or you learned a great
deal from the Hound and some you claim
that she sometimes acts like him it says
that re also reunites with Gentry a
scene which fans hope might give us a
clue about the upcoming wedding but as a
theory for another time the two shared a
lot of time together in previous seasons
and both grew to like and deeply cared
for each other
it's safe to say they'll be happy to see
each other alive and well Jorah and Sam
will reunite as well
Sam save George life in the previous
season but your screen burned Sims
father and brother alive even though
juror took no part in it and even though
Sam was nothing good terms with his
family it's still going to be
interesting to see how the same react to
such news perhaps one of the reunions
that most fans will love to finally see
is the one between sense and Tyrion once
a married couple the two will surely be
happy to see each other after a long
time Tyrion was the only answer that
cared first our daughter and actually
tried to make her time at King's Landing
a bit better he protected her from King
Joffrey numerous times leading Sansa to
trust earring they have both been
through some rough times since then and
one or two scenes between those two
would be great to see if I'd have to
guess I'd say that Tyrion will s sense a
how she's kept his landing and how they
managed to see through a little fingers
game the a final says that January
netted ghosts as well and I can only say
finally we all enjoy the dragons by the
direwolves have also been a huge part of
the game of Thrones especially of the
stark children we haven't seen ghost
ever since Jon's been resurrected
probably wondering where Ghost even is
he's at Winterfell the sure iners
confirmed that ghost remained at
Winterfell with sense 7 Jon left to meet
Danny on Dragonstone as a matter of fact
ghost was supposed to be in one scene of
the previous season when discussing his
episode stoned born on season 7 blu-ray
commentary track writer cogman revealed
that he wrote a scene featuring ghost
but it got cut we were supposed to see
ghost when Jon emerged from interval
crypts right after he threatened
Littlefinger but before he waved goodbye
to Sansa
so somewhere in there goes to supposed
to finally reappear cogman provided some
more details there was a bit here where
Janki
out of the crypts and ghosts came up to
him and he petted him and said take care
of sensor watch over her for me but I
guess those direwolf's are expensive I
guess it got cut
instead of goes the showrunners decided
to fulfill their long waited dish of
having an undead bearing Game of Thrones
this year made perfect sense that you
could have one of these things out there
and we really put our our four feet down
and we said god damn it we want the
zombie polar bear they were supposed to
have more go scenes in season six as
well but they eventually decided to
rather have more giant Z's director of
the battle the Basterds revealed that it
was a budgetary concern
he said ghost was in there in spades
originally but it's also an incredibly
time-consuming and expensive character
to bring to life he continued with
ultimately we had to choose between one
one and the dire wolf so the dog bit the
dust anyways the Game of Thrones
production had much higher budget for
Season eight and with that said it only
makes sense for girls to finally
reappear the other sells January night
with ghost in Episode two and I'm sure
we'll see more of him in the following
episodes especially in the battle for
Winterfell that is taking place in
episode three back to the outline it
says that after initial greetings jack
has been told about both the fall of the
wall and followed alas hurt Jon commands
everyone to gather in the Great Hall of
Winterfell to discuss how will they
defend north against the night king and
his army the northern Lords are not
pleased except the near Caesar Queen
Daenerys doesn't say a word
John states that Danny came to the
North's aid we told her armies and
dragons without her the war would be
lost during the meeting census says that
Cersei cannot be trusted honesty
reassures them that again
John orders Winterfell defenses to be
made out of journalist journals says
that every man and women must carry a
dragon less weapon as well there's not
much to say about this part John and
Danny are having a meeting with more
Lords regarding how they plan to stand
against the army of the dead it's not
surprising that most of the Lords are
not eager to accept any answer Queen but
I'm sure John speech will change their
mind John will likely also revealed to
them that Dany has already sacrificed
one dragon in order to help the north it
should make them a be less angry about
Johnny linked to the dragon queen
John ordering Winterfell defenses to be
made out of journalist and everyone
carrying a journalist weapon has been
expected but it's also been confirmed by
leaked photos about which I'm going to
talk a bit later in this video since I
spent quite a lot of time at Cersei and
it seems that she might see through
Circe's game doubting her intentions and
saying that sir
she cannot be trusted the Outland and
stays dead sometime later in the episode
John and Danny are in the crypts John
has learned about history lineage Danny
doesn't know yet
they discussed Nets death the scene ends
with a horn being blown let me stop
right here to say that this part is both
surprising and expected we've known that
John must find the truth in the
beginning of the season even though this
rough outline doesn't provide assonance
regarding who will be the one to reveal
it to him in the very beginning of the
episode Sam did tell John that they need
to speak in private
so Sam I be the one to reveal him this
game-changing information anyways this
scene in the crypts between John and
Danny might even be confirmed by the
leaks months after I had received the
Sultan it was revealed that episode 2
will see the return of the crypts which
was being filmed on its long-standing
location at Shane's castle it's also
been reported that two main characters
will discuss Ned Stark's death in this
particular scene even the scenes ending
with the horn being blown has been
confirmed by the leaks the outline then
states that the next scene takes place
in red keep the aftermath of Circe's
miscarriage Cersei has gone completely
mad after what's happened to her in the
last episode she becomes more ruthless
and more paranoid
Qyburn enters her chambers but Cersei
does not speak of her miscarriage she
says that she doesn't want to hear it
and instead asks how are the planes
going I burn ants and toss her see that
everything goes well and that they
should reach quite Harbor any day now
the scene then switches to young Ranger
and his armed fleet he's sailing with
the golden company towards north in the
season premieres ending with so Cersei
having a miscarriage it says that Cersei
doesn't want to speak of the another
child she just lost we've already seen
this approach in the previous season as
she did not want to speak about Tom and
me Jaime the outline says that Cersei
goes full mad and honestly it's been
expected this child was her only
remaining hope regarding the future of
her in her house with it being lost I
can see Cersei now becoming the Met
Queen with only one desire to destroy
our enemies no matter the cost
the surprising part of this is your
great joy and his our own fleet it seems
that he's sailing with the golden
company towards north perhaps Episode
three will not see John and any fighting
the knight King only perhaps they'll
have to fight urine and the golden
company as well after all urine promised
Cersei to destroy the pretenders in the
North the iron fleet who owned the Seas
you can defeat the invaders in East and
the pretenders in the north and south
then we're back at Winterfell again the
outline says that we see a bird's-eye
shot of the unsullied the dragon
glass-tipped spear swith in the walls
subinterval we also see the de track
outside though the track huts are being
built outside the Winterfell walls let
me stop right there to say that this
part has already been confirmed by the
leaked photos their photos that are
showing 3d tracking huts to smaller and
one larger Hut all at the Titanic story
of symbol fest which is where the Game
of Thrones production mainly films this
is a de jakke Hut the kind we last saw
back in season six when then he was
taken to the way his dog track to live
out her life in endless widowhood the
third larger hut is suggested by many
sources to be a heart where Danny will
stay let me remind you once again that
as already said and as you can see by
yourself I receive this outline back in
August of last year that's a couple of
months before Game of Thrones started
filming its final season couple months
before any leaked photo was taken in it
this outline seems to be perfectly
matching with all the leagues that
followed anyways then is coming to the
north side with her full strength even
though it does seem like there might be
some extra space for the unsullied
inside the Winterfell walls it certainly
cannot take tens of thousands of the
Jackie and therefore Dembele huts
outside Winterfell is not coming as a
huge surprise back to the outline we're
still at Winterfell
Ellis Karstark finally reaches
Winterfell bran stark warns Jon that the
army of the Dead is very close Jaime
bran arrive at River the episode ends
with the army of the Dead approaching
Winterfell the horn is being blown in
the season premiere Carter's barely
managed to flee car call just before the
end that reaches it with the Karstarks
arrival at Winterfell there also comes
the army of the Dead there have the guys
season 8 episode 2 leaked outline that
was sent to me in August of last year
months before Game of Thrones began
filming its final season once before any
leaked photos were taken and yet it
seems to be supported by all the leaks
that eventually appeared as already
stated I received outline for every
single episode of the final season and
that's what I'll be covering in the
following days some of you might think
that this season seems to be a bit slow
paced especially since it's the last
season however keep in mind that this is
only a rough outline they're going to be
very more scenes these are basically the
episodes highlights for example there
has not been yet a mention of the in
Greater Los Angeles incurrent EU that
will see both of them in either season
premiere or in this very episode is just
that they're seeing certain are the
episodes highlights anyways this episode
still seems to be quite exciting
with John and Danny finally arriving at
Winterfell we'll see many reunions
general finally learned the truth and he
will finally reunite with ghost Cersei
on the other hand has gone fully mad and
urine is sailing north the night King is
coming for Winterfell in the north is
preparing for the final stand the next
episode will be action-packed with a
huge battle for Winterfell the Jaime
Lannister almost dying and Yura Granger
capturing Jon Snow that's all I can say
about the next episode stay tuned peace
[Music]
[Music]